entrada de buenos días y saludamos
también a nuestros invitados hoy tenemos
a marie christine doran investigadora y
profesora en la escuela de estudios
políticos en la universidad de ottawa
bienvenida muchas gracias y riccardo
peñafiel profesor e investigador en el
departamento de ciencias políticas de la
universidad de quebec en montreal
bienvenido riccardo a la y bueno con
ellos vamos a conversar sobre los
resultados preliminares de una misión
canadiense de observación sobre
violaciones de los derechos humanos en
chile ellos formaron parte de esta
delegación pero primero y antes que todo
un caluroso saludo a todos ustedes allá
del otro lado del micrófono y de la
pantalla de las cámaras y bueno deseamos
que este programa de hoy sea de su total
agrado muchísimas gracias por su
agradable compañía
pero antes de entrar de lleno con
nuestros invitados y de entrar de lleno
con este castor cibernético
no sé si hay algo insólito por ahí
que haya causado a mí me encantan las
efemérides son interesantes esta vez
poco en realidad lo que hago es buscar
la semana la semana pasada hasta el día
de este fin de semana que es donde sale
el programa en internet mientras tanto
les cuento que el día 10 de febrero fue
el día mundial de las legumbres
vegetariano hay que festejarlo una buena
ensalada
cada dos semanas
el día internacional de la mujer y la
niña en la ciencia
eso es un día internacional tampoco lo
conocíamos el 11 también es el día
internacional de la epilepsia la jornada
mundial del enfermo y el día
internacional del día del internet
seguro no existe
el 12 el día mundial contra el uso del
niño soldado
el 13 es el día mundial de la radio
estuvo festejando las radios asociadas a
la radio rumanía internacional y radio
praga interna exacto el 13 también fue
el día mundial en realidad me parece muy
gracioso pues el día mundial del soltero
que es el día de san valentín el 13 le
puso el día mundial del soltero y por el
san valentín en nos toca bien el corazón
bien el profundo en el corazón también
es el día mundial de la cardiopatía
congénita
de corazón
es una relación lógica de todos esos
días internacionales así que esa es la
efemérides de días internacionales no
vamos a meter en detalles quién nació y
murió el normal
pero veremos los días internaciones de
sobre todo algo que fantástico luis
laborda tú nos hablas de iphone y de
monedas
si yo estoy hablábamos precisamente de
la necesidad o el deseo que tiene mucha
gente uno se incluye a veces en eso
también de cambiar su teléfono móvil
este aparato que todos disponemos
últimamente o la mayoría
del costo que tienen estos teléfonos y
de lo caro que es muchas veces este
momento que uno quiere tiene que
renovarlos y yo te comentaba el otro día
precisamente de que tengo ganas de
cambiarlo por uno que tenga una pantalla
un poco más grande para poder ver vídeos
más cómodamente etcétera bueno que
aguanta las ganas me aguanto las ganas
pues sobre todo en mi bolsillo es el que
me está obligando a aguantarlo me da
otro día de día me olvidará de está
ahora la información aquí pero diga el
caso de un estudiante ex estudiante aquí
en canadá que comentaba el caso de un ex
compañero de estudios en territorio
canadiense que cuando llegó el momento
de renovar su teléfono en este caso es
pues específicamente un iphone
fue acumulando moneda sobre moneda a lo
largo de un año y después de un año de
juntar monedita por monedita tuvo el
dinero suficiente para comprarse un
iphone teléfono que yo uso desde hace
muchos años pero que vengo diciendo
desde hace ya tiempo que se ha puesto en
caprichoso si digamos en irracionalmente
caro
es uno de los teléfonos vendidos es
comprensible de historia que mientras
más caro más vendidos o por lo menos
digamos sigue ahí a cabeza cabeza bueno
con la colonia lo que es uno de los
modelos más caros en este momento puesto
de oro creo que es de dos mil quinientos
dólares y hay muchísima gente que
encuentra razón suficiente pero no
solamente encuentra la razón encuentra
los billetes suficientes para comprarse
uno dos mil 500 dólares un precio que ya
me parece fuera de toda racionalidad así
que bueno
este personaje el cual tú hablas que
ahorro moneda por moneda me imagino que
era moneda de diez centavos alcanza que
ahorrar monedas sobre monedas a lo largo
de un año para comprar un teléfono móvil
la experiencia me hubiese parecido aún
más dolorosa pero tú sabes el cuñado mío
solía antes vaciarse el bolsillo de
todas las monedas que tenía y los echaba
en un recipiente todos los días decía
eso y al final del año pues con eso se
podía comprar un tiquete de avión para
irse de vacaciones el año no igual hay
que tener ahora en la época del paypass
justamente de las cosas lo usamos las
tarjetas el casi casi no hay dinero en
efectivo
dando vueltas imagínense yo que tengo un
billete cada tres meses más o menos la
mano chocolate claro
y hablando de aguantarse la canasta él
me hace pensar en un chiste de un amigo
mío que decía tengo unas ganas de
trabajar pero me las aguas
lo mío es un poco más bueno ni más ni
menos cómico pero es esta historia que
muy probablemente ustedes oyeron en
radio canadá esto sucedió en saint en la
región sangre de una pareja que bueno
hizo su mercado como siempre lo hacía
todas las semanas y entre las verduras
que habían comprado compraron pimientos
verdes no y la sorpresa de la señora fue
grande cuando al cortar el pimiento se
dio cuenta que estaba así rico proteínas
agregadas porque había una ranita había
una ranita viva
ahí está la ranita y la ranita pues
menos menos mal que encontró la la
ranita y no media realista
porque hubiera sido bastante estrés y si
hubiera sido cruel para la pobre señora
de haber asesinado pero sabes que que el
final de la ranita fue trágico de todas
formas porque llamaron al ministerio de
agricultura de quebec para informarles
no de esto porque ellos son los que se
encargan también de toda la seguridad de
las cosas que se importan alimentos
verduras y todo esto y la mataron a la
granja la a la ranita para analizarla
para ver si no había ninguna
problema eventual no de transmisión de
alguna enfermedad etc
sin nada más que un pobre ranita
entonces eso me pareció curioso y muy
insólito que vayas y te llevas una
sorpresa cuando bajas
ahora encontrarse una ranita y no el año
pasado encontraron cucarachas dentro de
una de estas ensaladas que vienen
cerradas las sirvieron así presionan el
vinagre y estaba la cara hechas revisión
y recibiendo el vinagre así o sea hay
que tener mucho cuidado porque se
empaquetada por ahí no se pasa todos los
controles de calidad entonces habría que
mirar con mucha atención
bueno pues seamos cuidadosos en lo que
respecta a las cucarachas y bueno ahora
sí regresamos con nuestros invitados de
hoy marie christine doran y ricardo
peñafiel que como decíamos al principio
formaron parte de una delegación
canadiense de observación sobre
violaciones de derechos humanos en chile
una delegación formada por diversas por
personas de diversas especializaciones
campos de intervención disputa
a 2 etcétera y bueno ustedes regresaron
hace poco en qué momento se llevó a cabo
esta esta misión
marie christine bueno la misión se llevó
a cabo del 18 al 27 de enero y se
terminó con una conferencia de prensa en
santiago donde fue un éxito
absolutamente habéis avaya sordos porque
hasta llegó se tienen a santiago a
escucharla 18 medios de comunicación en
chile y nosotros lo interpretamos como
que en chile la verdad es que estaban
mirando mucho hacia canadá que es un
país con el cual chile tiene muchos
lazos comerciales y culturales etcétera
y fue muy importante la presencia de
canadienses en ese momento para decir
bueno nosotros estamos aquí en
solidaridad con la sociedad chilena que
se está movilizando desde ya hace tres
meses casi para reclamar una asamblea
constituyente plena y varias cosas
terminar con las desigualdades de ese
país que es uno de los más desiguales de
américa latina cuántas personas formaban
parte de esta delegación
29 y la especificidad de la delegación
es que éramos cinco académicos tres
sindicalistas yo tenían los dos sobreros
y dos diputados en las tres principales
centrales un diputado de provincial otro
del federal entonces era bastante
interesante esta composición que también
nos permitía la diferencia de otras
otros informes que han sido hechos por
organizaciones especializada en derechos
humanos nosotros teníamos una concepción
más general de los derechos humanos como
algo que son integrales y solidarios e
indivisibles entonces el derecho laboral
el derecho también a la manifestación o
sea más allá de la manifestación
derechos sociales y justamente el
análisis que hacemos es también los
orígenes a partir de la dictadura y
también se dice no son 30 pesos son 30
años son 30 años del neoliberalismo
y justamente con una pseudodemocracia
que mantuvo la constitución pinochetista
de 1980 y esa constitución está hecha
contra los derechos sociales a la salud
la educación el alojamiento y todo eso
porque es una constitución neoliberal
que quita la concepción republicana en
la cual se reconocía el derecho los
derechos sociales entonces esos derechos
sociales que han sido vulnerados durante
todos estos años son los que explican el
estallido social y también la impunidad
hace que las fuerzas del orden
se comporten como extremadamente
represivas aquí y en qué consistió el
trabajo como tal mire nosotros estuvimos
haciendo más de 65 horas de entrevista
digamos durante 7 días entonces fueron
días muy llenos
vimos a 52 organizaciones entre las
cuales hay una gran variedad por ejemplo
estaban bueno el colegio de médicos de
chile el colegio periodistas que también
son agredidos ellos al intentar de dar
algún tipo de ayuda a la población civil
que está en las calles hay médicos que
tienen ahí balines o sea tienen heridas
muy graves y lamentablemente carabineros
de chile apunta hacia los ojos de
periodistas y médicos es llegar a los
medios muchas personas que habían
perdido
[Música]
227 personas con lesiones oculares de
las cuales más de 30 han perdido un ojo
y dos personas dos ojos y eso incluye un
periodista de megas noticias que es un
canal bien centrista
digamos y hielera iba bien identificado
y perdió el ojo entonces ese es bueno
entre las personas que conocimos fueron
esas asociaciones muy importantes como
portavoces también del movimiento
organizaciones sindicales feministas
en este momento muy muy fuertes y muy
representativas de un anhelo de la
sociedad chilena de terminar con todas
las violencias es el lema de la fe de
las feministas actualmente terminemos
con todas las violencias en contra de
cualquier persona no solamente bueno
contra las mujeres todavía hay muchas
pero además ellas proponen como un
cambio total de cultura y obviamente
oponiéndose a la represión entonces
conocimos pudimos hablar con víctimas
99 personas que nos dieron su testimonio
y lo cual como conclusión tenemos muy
claro de que la represión en chile sigue
los protocolos de carabineros que ellos
mismos se han dado no se aplican y el
gobierno chileno lo que más nos preocupa
a nosotros es que en este momento
nosotros hablamos con la subsecretaría
de derechos humanos del ministerio de
justicia y ellos no reconocen
violaciones de derechos humanos hasta
que esas violaciones hayan sido juzgadas
en un tribunal lo cual obviamente se
demora mucho tiempo entonces el juego
en este momento de parte del gobierno
chileno es decir bueno hay dos hay dos
violaciones reconocidas porque hay dos
casos que fueron juzgados pero nada más
el resto no sabemos qué pasa y es
tremendamente absurdo frente a las que
hace falta para que este proceso para
que cambie comiencen estos juicios para
que realmente se tome el que no se dé
cuenta efectivamente qué es lo que pasa
que se tomen medidas para que esto siga
pasando bueno lamentablemente en chile
mientras no le duele el bolsillo a la
burguesía la oligarquía está va a seguir
lamentablemente lo que permite estas
violaciones sistemáticas de los derechos
y masivas de los derechos humanos es un
sistema global en el sentido que los
jueces van a hay 2.000 personas
actualmente con cárcel preventiva por
delitos menores así por pegarle romper
un estar rompiendo un entorno y qué
eso ni siquiera tiene cárcel como pena
máxima que puedes tener por eso el
vandalismo no nos lleva a cárcel y sin
embargo la persona un profesor estuvo en
cárcel durante 30 días hasta que
lograron sacar porque porque lo ponían
bajo causas de terrorismo pero
los jueces colaboran lamentablemente no
todos pero colaboran con este tipo de
también prejuicio entonces se permiten
comentarios diciéndole a los jóvenes que
no tenían por qué protestar si no
protestaran no tendrían los problemas
que están que están denunciando entonces
esta justicia que además aplica leyes
nacionales que están en contradicción
con convenciones internacionales
firmadas por chile en teoría esas
convenciones internacionales fueron
integradas sin embargo los jueces se
interpretan la ley chilena
además hay leyes hay decretos porque la
ley chilena permite la manifestación la
constitución aún siendo pinochetista
salvo que un decreto del 83 de estipula
tal tal cosa entonces están utilizando
leyes de la dictadura decretos de la
dictadura para aplicar esa represión
entonces ahí están los jueces que
colaboran y no sólo eso todo el sistema
también la administración a los dos
hospitales que le dicen
le dan como orden administrativa a los
médicos de las enfermeras no registrar
el origen de las heridas porque porque
las cifras son realmente dan miedo pero
esas cifras son ni siquiera un tercio de
lo que está ocurriendo porque no se está
registrando hay gente que es desaparecía
no como antes que se desvanecía para
siempre pero que van a ser golpeados en
los autos patrullas dejados en el borde
y nunca se registró el arresto y hay
gente que ha muerto así entonces igual
se encontró press encontró el cuerpo y
así los vídeos son diferentes nada uno
ve en las redes sociales la gente está
haciendo un trabajo súper intenso yo
tengo muchos contactos chilenos y lo que
se ve es realmente la pena y dada la
amargura que ni siquiera eso porque
digamos estamos viviendo en la era de la
imagen del vídeo y ni siquiera eso ayuda
a que las autoridades digan está pasando
o sea se ningunea a lo que la gente hace
y se sigue aplicando mano dura y sin
tipo sin ningún tipo de restricción
cuando es evidente que lo que está
pasando no está bien y hay algún plan
digamos porque esto ustedes decían que
el origen es de la época desde la época
de pinochet no es cierto
por qué tardó tanto en surgir este
descontento qué fue lo que pasó en chile
para que esto acontezca ahora
pero después tu regreso con la muerte
las presiones que queremos el ser sobre
canadá porque lamentablemente estamos
hablando de los teléfonos el litio y los
intereses mineros que nadie se haya
limitan la voluntad de canadá de hacer
presión pero ahora como por qué tardó
tanto en uno nosotros maría cristina
escribió un libro sería tu pregunta en
el cual sitúa en el 2003 el momento en
que chile despertó o sea despertó hace
mucho tiempo es algo que justamente este
sistema político chileno que es
justamente en la política de los
acuerdos no los acuerdos sociales con
los actores sociales sino que acuerdos
entre partidos políticos para excluir
los sectores sociales manifestaciones y
movimientos sociales no dejaron de haber
desde el primer día de la posdictadura
al salvo que siempre reprimidos
menospreciado desde entonces lo que
ocurrió hoy en día es que hoy en día
están estallando todos uno de los puntos
más fuertes es no más
afp esos son los las pensiones privadas
eso la potenciación individual que hace
que la gente que se quedó en el antiguo
sistema
de antes de la dictadura recibe tres
veces más la pensión tres veces más y
quien se llevó esa plata fueron los
capitales privados que muchas veces le
pertenecen a los mismos diputados
entonces y esto está encima el sistema
no funciona hoy en día está lleno de
todos los jubilados son muy pero muy
pobres reciben menos de 300 dólares al
mes con costos de la vida
iguales a los que hay aquí entonces
fenómeno de suicida es ese movimiento
llegó a convocar un millón de personas
hace un año en una manifestación otro
movimiento muy fuerte son las feministas
que al convocar una huelga general el 8
de marzo pasado hoy en día
va a volver a empezar las
manifestaciones que no se olviden que
son cotidianas la represión sigue porque
las manifestaciones siguen al cada día
hay por lo menos una manifestación por
ciudad a santiago presta todas las
ciudades no paran la gente de
manifestarse y bueno entonces el 8 de
marzo vuelve con todo porque sea
el verano es como el 8 de septiembre el
equivalente aquí internacional de las
mujeres y entonces el 8 y el 9 porque lo
choca un domingo entonces el 9 una
huelga general
feminista pero trans seccionales
intersección ar el sentido de que
feministas que trabajan el nivel
sindical a nivel del medio ambiente a
todos los niveles es la articulación
justamente una perspectiva contra todas
las violencias en todos los aspectos
recordemos y eso es muy importante que
hubo un acuerdo entre los partidos en el
mes de noviembre para tener una asamblea
constituyente o sea un voto para decidir
el 26 de abril si la población chilena
quiere tener una asamblea constituyente
con 50 por ciento de partidos o
plenamente constituyente y ahora al
comienzo eso fue muy mal recibido por
parte de la población civil porque sé
que se acordó de que no habían no había
paridad de género en la asamblea tampoco
habían digamos puestos para pueblos
indígenas que fueran ya representativos
de su número
entonces mucha gente protestaba en
contra de ese acuerdo pero en este
momento la verdad nosotros hemos visto
casi todas las organizaciones están
empujando para que se gane el voto a la
asamblea constituyente a favor de la
asamblea y la asamblea plena y eso vemos
que hay un cambio y la verdad la gente
allá está muy preocupada de que la
represión sea aún más fuerte si es
posible durante el mes de marzo porque
lo que vemos es que y es una de las
conclusiones de la delegación de las
naciones unidas también y de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos en
este momento el gobierno chileno está
apuntando a que la gente va a tener
tanto miedo va a tener terror de salir a
la calle por eso vemos violaciones por
parte de carabineros cosas que nos
explican no si no es para decir ustedes
no se metan a la calle y entonces la
apuesta es que la gente se calme y vaya
a su casa y vemos que eso no está
sucediendo al contrario exactamente y de
hecho se habla en chiles
en un marco de supuesta democracia y
hablando de terrorismo de estado
justamente hubo alguna interferencia por
parte del estado mientras ustedes
estaban haciendo su trabajo
eso es muy cómico porque con nosotros no
hicieron nada sino digamos con la
subsecretaría de derechos humanos
mandaron a personas que fueron muy
amables pero que no eran los delegados
que esperábamos no digamos los
representantes y nos la embajada tampoco
nos recibió de canadá
entonces pero sabían que estaban muy
ocupados posiblemente pero la cosa es
que después de nosotros vino por una
segunda visita a la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos y ahí
sí el gobierno chileno dijo ustedes no
tienen por qué meterse en asuntos
internos y eso es muy grave es un
precedente porque pues eso también
demuestra que el chileno está dispuesto
a respetar las convenciones crean
nosotros no nos no nos han dicho nada
la línea común entre chile y canadá es
que chile es un estado de derecho que en
el cual justamente canadá
subrayó el hecho de que chile permitía
las comisiones internacionales de entrar
entonces ese fue como un error se les
dentro de la línea argumentativa
retórica del gobierno chileno decir que
ya basta de comisiones internacionales
que la injerencia pero tampoco prosperó
esa ese argumento en la línea que tienen
es que justamente yo son un estado
derecho que transparente que permiten
organismos internacionales de venir y
ver lo que está pasando esa parte es
verdad pero justamente cuando esta y que
ellos dicen se cumple la ley salvo que
si 38 casos sobre miles de querellas
sólo son procesados entonces la ley
había un artículo justamente decía así
demora no es justicia para dar vuelta
eso es la de justicia de muera pero
llega en este caso se demora tanto si
desean dentro de cinco años se establece
que el gobierno tenía responsabilidad en
violaciones de derechos humanos va a ser
muy tarde actualmente se están violando
sistemáticamente con complicidad del
sistema y entonces eso es un sistema de
derecho sí pero dentro del cual el
derecho está es disfuncional con sus
funciones de ahora yo quería ahondar en
eso y precisamente preguntarles cuál
creen ustedes que debería ser la
respuesta del gobierno canadiense a la
situación en chile porque tenemos que
recordar que la semana próxima hay aquí
en canadá una reunión del grupo de lima
en el cual el país va a aprovechar para
reiterar su preocupación por la
situación en venezuela
pero esa preocupación no es igual no es
equiparable a la que ha demostrado está
agua por la situación que se vive en
chile con la reiterada violación a los
derechos humanos que vienen ocurriendo
desde hace meses y con la cantidad de
gente como decía ricardo cardona cierto
el nombre de detenidos que ha habido no
solamente tiene sol y fiero con lo que
tú has dicho no se trata solamente de
faltas menores sino recordamos todos
porque lo han respetado incluso los
medios sociales de comunicación las
detenciones arbitrarias al tuntún como
se dice de gente que ha sido levantada
de la calle de caminando que estuviera
cometiendo ningún tipo de delito ni
falta
canadá que respuesta ha dado o cual
debería dar a esta situación
bueno justamente nosotros primero que
todos queremos decir que estamos
trabajando con varias organizaciones de
la comunidad chilena aquí en canadá que
han sido muy activos y ellos han hecho
peticiones varias peticiones de hecho
hay una petición en este momento en el
parlamento por una diputada del npd
helénico han de vancouver para que el
gobierno canadiense sea muy claro en
cuanto al rechazo de esas violaciones a
los derechos humanos y que llame la
atención del gobierno de perdón del
gobierno chileno en respetar las
convenciones internacionales porque en
este momento la respuesta ha sido del
gobierno canadiense bueno vemos con
digamos beneplácito el hecho de que
chile permita la entrada de las misiones
internacionales como dice y eso es
cierto que es bueno porque en venezuela
por ejemplo no se le permitió a la
comisión interamericana entrar de nuevo
bueno dicho sea de paso pero sin embargo
más allá de eso no hay ninguna
condenación y vemos que por ejemplo
pueblos
y mujeres que son prioridades supuestas
del gobierno canadiense están siendo
vulneradas atacadas sin ningún tipo de
respuesta y el gobierno canadiense nos
ha dicho desde la conferencia de prensa
de la semana pasada que estaban buscando
una solución inclusiva con el gobierno
chileno lo cual no quiere decir mucho
entonces si la idea es justamente y eso
es muy importante la comunidad chilena
dice porque cuando se trata de la
comunidad venezolana en canadá que
obviamente está más opuesta al gobierno
actual de maduro si el gobierno
canadiense responde y nosotros que la
inmensa mayoría como chile
yo no soy chilena pero ellos dicen
nosotros estamos opuestos a las
violaciones de derechos humanos de
nuestro país y nuestro gobierno
canadiense no dice nada no entienden
están muy muy muy preocupados con esa
situación hay un peso dos medidas antes
de despedir a nuestros invitados
leonardo tenemos algún comentario de
oyentes uno uno solo y en este caso se
esa rodillas char decía en últimas que
está pasando en chile que es
qué se busca con todo esto la pregunta
si es con todo esto la participación
internacional la canadiense o con todo
esto lo que está pasando socialmente así
que mi posición es que lo que está
ocurriendo en chile es una revolución
justamente se llegó hasta el límite de
lo tolerable de este neoliberalismo
brutal que fue impuesto de forma militar
y después que fue mantenido de forma
ideológica pero también sumamente
represiva la ley antiterrorista que se
le aplicó sistemáticamente a los
mapuches pueblos indígenas del sur de
chile todo tipo de acción justamente a
favor de en contra del extractivismo y
de la destrucción de la naturaleza es
reprimida con una fuerza increíble y
como dicen las feministas todas las
mujeres contra todas las violencias es
un frente que está en todas partes
entonces esa lucha contra todo tipo de
autoritarismo que existe en chile desde
hace 46 años eso va y por eso para mi
modo de ver es una revolución feminista
el 8 de marzo y el 9 de marzo va a ser
muy fuerte hay mucha gente que apuesta a
la caída del gobierno porque tiene 6% de
apoyo el sistema de partido tiene 3 por
ciento de apoyo entonces como un
gobierno y un sistema de partidos o
instituciones que no tienen ninguna
legitimidad pretenden seguir la única
respuesta que da el gobierno ha sido
leyes represivas que van aún más o sea
lo que era prohibido antes ahora se va a
volver ley pero eso no es una solución
entonces no se la pregunta es que lo
hiciera de parte del gobierno de parte
de la cia de parte de nosotros que
estamos haciendo allá nosotros
respondimos al llamado del alto
comisionado de derechos humanos de las
naciones unidas que con ellos estamos
trabajando en chile nos encontramos con
ellos ellos han dicho que necesitan más
delegaciones que vayan para demostrar
que las violaciones siguen ocurriendo
entonces la gran preocupación de
naciones unidas y de la comisión
interamericana decir no está terminando
y eso también hace que no se solucionen
las cosas
que la gente está totalmente
desconcertada entre tanta violencia
entonces igual que el cambio no tendría
que ser estético digamos poner otro
partido sino un cambio de raíz que
realmente erradique todo lo que viene
hace 30 años realmente yo sé que ustedes
tienen otros compromisos amigos ustedes
presentaron este informe preliminar y
cuál es la próxima etapa
bueno el informe va a salir de aquí un
par de semanas hay una campaña también
con la comunidad chilena o los diversos
grupos que se organizaron al calor de
esta represión increíble que ha surgido
para hacer precioso el gobierno
canadiense es importantísimo que el
gobierno tenga alguna forma de que tenga
que pagar por lo que está haciendo no
puedes seguir impune esta situación y la
única el único amparo que tiene la
población chilena hoy en día es la
comunidad internacional que tiene que
hacer presión y no va a ser sólo canadá
pero que nada tiene gran importancia
también por una relación privilegiada la
mayoría de la inversión en la minería
viene de canadá y el problema también
porque dentro uno habla de
neoliberalismo y pre cosa que inicie las
ocurre privatización del agua
privatización de ríos las compañías
mineras están comprando toda el agua
para su extracción de minerales y dejas
sin agua la pobla
son cosas que ni ni siquiera se queda
corta la palabra neoliberalismo para
entender lo que se está viviendo en
chile así que una campaña a partir de
aquí son las próximas etapas
lo vamos a hacer entonces no sólo el
informe sino que acompañado con mucha
gente que y el senado chileno la
oposición nos ha pedido que volvamos
como delegación internacional para
vigilar las elecciones en abril en abril
para la nueva constitución así que muy
bien ricardo peñafiel marie-christine
durán muchísimas gracias por haberse
desplazado hasta aquí hasta nuestros
estudios y muchísimas gracias por
ese sobrevuelo de la situación en chile
y bueno nosotros vamos a continuar acá
mi estimado y querido leonardo con
nuestra aplicación en una aplicación que
desde ya le pedimos a todos ustedes por
allá y a nuestros invitados que la baja
en que la de la bajen y la pues tengan
en sus teléfonos para mantenerse bien
informados así es la aplicación es la
manera más fácil más rápida y segura de
poder
chequear los contenidos que produce
radio canal internacional en las cinco
lenguas en realidad aconsejamos a los
que hablan español bajar la española en
el español pues venga vale también
tienen la posibilidad de bajada de
bajarlas en francés en inglés en árabe y
en chino para que esos que tenga no sólo
tenemos un oyente que por lo menos tres
aplicaciones tiene de todas estas así
que la recomendación es bajar la pueden
ver este programa que estamos haciendo
en el sector de vídeos nuestros vídeos
sale el programa en el momento en vivo y
en directo así que la recomendación es
bajar la aplicación pueden ir a nuestra
página internet a la derecha arriba
tienen un link en la publicidad de la
aplicación para ir a las dos tiendas
oficiales más grandes para los teléfonos
más caros y los no tan caros así que
bajar la aplicación de las dos tiendas
cuando lo deseen a partir de nuestra
página o bien yendo a estas tiendas de
apple
de android directamente y poniendo radio
canadá internacional en español bueno
pues ya si van a tener esta aplicación
en sus teléfonos celulares y bueno con
un solo clic pues van a tener acceso a
toda la información que nosotros
producimos aquí en radio canadá
internacional algún comentario por ahí
louis sí señor aquí tiene un mensaje que
nos envía javier gonzález nunca hará y
sobre el tema montreal prohibir a toda
la bolsa de plástico en su territorio un
tema que publicamos recientemente dice
javier gonzález nungaray creo que estas
determinaciones de las autoridades de
diferentes ciudades en este caso
montreal son buenos proyectos que si se
realizan vamos a mejorar la calidad de
vida de los ciudadanos en general es el
mensaje de javier si aquí con un poquito
presbicia tema el summum de montreal
hospital que nació con la ciudad
martha ovalle nos dice tuvo una urgencia
de septiembre del 2019 en su hospital y
quedarán de enviarme una factura y la
historia clínica lo cual no ha pasado y
nos piden nosotros
si podemos interceder para buscar la
factura y le decimos a marta que
lamentablemente nos encantaría para
ayudarle pero tiene que hablar
directamente con las autoridades de
pertinentes del hospital para poder
lograr hacerse de esa factura y antes de
pasar a nuestros temas que vamos a
sugerirles a nuestros oyentes que pueden
ir a ver si tienen la aplicación van a
ir directamente a nuestra aplicación
vamos a
quiero dar hoy en los controles técnicos
el crédito a leo boulanger a
pierre-louis play ya pierde útil sin
esas tres personas pues este programa no
estaría disponible para todos ustedes y
vamos ahora con los temas que hemos
tratado esta semana tú leonardo tú nos
hablas de un malware o de un programa
maligno no si es en realidad la
desmitificación de una historia larga
hace años que se viene hablando
justamente de que windows es mucho más
vulnerable a los virus que la empresa de
la manzana que macintosh en este caso ha
salido un estudio reciente hace un par
de semanas nada más donde dice que en
realidad no están así después de años y
años de campañas es más se utilizó una
campaña y la pongo ahí y después de 30
años de ser menos
que en realidad no es tan seguro como
como antes
y en realidad el estudio habla
puntualmente de que cualquier
dispositivo conectado a internet es
vulnerable hoy en día no es necesario
que sea más que android windows el que
sea es vulnerable porque digamos que la
tecnología con la que se recibe ahora y
con la que se ataca a estos dispositivos
es mucho más refinada que la que se
usaba hace 20 años atrás así que bueno
esto es como para contarles un poco de
qué se trata y la historia de esta gran
rivalidad entre mac
y windows también es cierto en la última
década los productos de la firma apple
se han hecho más populares y eso también
de su precio a pesar de su precio sí y
eso también puso en la mira de la
atención de quienes generan este tipo de
programas de espionaje de infección
etcétera que antes no se preocupan
demasiado porque tenían un mercado muy
muy reducido esto también lo dice en el
artículo hablando puntualmente de lo que
pasaba hace un par de años atrás
una década atrás y lo que pasa ahora
digamos es mucho más popular y hay mucha
más gente que accede a estos este tipo
de tipos de dispositivos entonces
la mirada de los hackers y la gente que
trata de robar también se posa sobre la
gente que tiene máquinas para más
información
rcn punto se ha luis laborda tú nos
hablas de la extensión de los servicios
de salud virtuales en canadá sí señora
se habla frecuentemente de la salud en
canadá y en quebec también en particular
y de los problemas que está esta área
enfrenta entre otras razones por una
carencia de profesionales de la salud y
por el envejecimiento de la población
son dos realidades que vive en canadá
desde hace tiempo y una de las
propuestas que ha surgido desde los
propios integrantes del área de la salud
es expandir los servicios de
telerrealidad de tres reglas perdón de
entere salud se puede decir hacer
posible la atención entre el médico y el
paciente a partir del uso de las nuevas
tecnologías diversos colegios
profesionales y organizaciones que
representan a médicos han dicho que esto
es posible que existe ya la tecnología
para llevarla a la práctica pero claro
hay un pequeño problema que yo lo
reflejó ahí en el artículo que es que
como todos sabemos el ejercicio de la
salud tanto en lo que hace a médicos
como enfermeras y a otras actividades
que participan del área es que estos
están regidos por colegios
es que han tomado y lo digo con total
este
me hago cargo de lo que digo entro plazo
que han tomado la actividad bajo su
órbita de influencia y decisión va a
decidir en términos castizos estos
colegios no permiten que otros vengan y
se metan en su campo de acción y el
proyecto en cuestión lo principal que
reclama este proyecto en cuestión es que
la salud sea una cuestión nacional que
no reconozca fronteras entre las
provincias algo que no creo que sea del
agrado de los colegios colegios no sólo
desde el colegio de médicos de acá sino
de todas las provincias ningún cada uno
pues tiene su música va a dar que ver
qué va a ver yo quiero verte que
realmente la tele salud o la salud a
distancia o la salud virtual como decías
vos qué es lo que dice también el
artículo puede hacer una realidad aquí
en canadá y sobre todo a corto plazo
como pretenden las autoridades hay un
proyecto piloto si no me equivoco o
también de sensation artículos sobre
esto hace un par de meses atrás
el hospital judío de montreal
tiene un proyecto para gente de edad que
tiene problemas de desplazamiento para
justamente evitarle la necesidad de
salir con la nieve y todo para poder
hacer este tipo de consultas que por ahí
la gente
mayor tiene como más reflejos
me duele algo preguntó al médico
entonces tienen que desplazarse y para
ese tipo de cosas hay un proyecto piloto
pero esto ya va mucho más allá de un
proyecto piloto y yo alguna vez es un
artículo hace un tiempo atrás también
sobre la gente que no los médicos en
provincias que no alcanzan a vivir con
lo que ganan entonces tratan de trabajar
en otras provincias pero no los dejan
porque los colegios profesionales y la
legislación provincial le impide poder
trabajar entonces tiene que pagar
licencia en las dos ciudades que en
realidad se hace increíble va a ser muy
simple yo por mi parte los invito a
escuchar este programa especial que
hicimos el día ayer jueves de sobre el
día mundial de la radio este programa
fue que en colaboración con tres radios
asociadas de radio canadá internacional
fue suiza info radio rumanía
internacional y radio praga
internacional puede ser fue un encuentro
muy simpático muy
entero solíamos solíamos en otras épocas
cuando estábamos en la onda corta hacer
programas en colaboración con las otras
radios asociadas y bueno para mí fue un
gran placer pues poder compartir estos
momentos con colegas de esas radios y
bueno todavía nos queda un minuto
leonardo si no no preguntaba hay algún
desarrollo que sigue todavía en onda
corta o radio rumanía y radio praga
siguen en la onda corta pero swissinfo
desde hace unos 20 años que está solo en
el portal dineral porque es perfecto sí
bueno y eso fue todo por este programa
de hoy
viernes 14 de febrero de 2020 en vivo y
en directo feliz residente
nosotros nos pusimos acá pues a tono con
el día estos 20 días sin cerca sarcasmo
que lindo montreal en envión
jajaja bueno nos acompañaron en estudio
pues de leonardo ti - luis laborda y en
el estudio también estuvieron marie
christine doran ricardo peñafiel y bueno
me despido simplemente diciéndoles hasta
la próxima
[Música]
a mí